hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the Gibraltar 2020
chess festival it's Parham actual vs.
Andre cpincombe are two of the the
leaders of the tournament and it's it's
really quite a game I was gonna show it
yesterday but then it really lasts for a
very long time and I thought okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it tomorrow
but was I surprised and I will show you
what I mean by this and also a lot of
you said that you saw that pregnant
under the field the Charter Mahmud II
are in round 8 now but you couldn't find
the moose test because the game never
happened
Mahmoud Arab is ill and he withdrew from
the tournament no idea no idea what's
going on but must be pretty serious as
well you don't just well withdraw from
the tournament when you are basically
amongst the leaders so I will keep you
informed that being said let's check out
this really really crazy game so much
rule opens with E 4 we have E 5 by AC
panco Knight f3 knight c6 and Bishop to
c4 so at the Italian game is on the
board we have Bishop to c5 and now of
course the Evans gambit was not played
in this game so c3 are continuing in the
in the calm style we have Knight to f6
and now d3 so the joke o piano game is
on the board we have castles castles and
now d5 as a white allow that so of
course black will play it with it
captures on d5 Knight captures and now
Knight B to d2 so this has all been
played a lot of times and as they ended
there's a lot of theory on this well
line nights the b6 attacking the bishop
and now mostly people play Bishop to b5
here which makes sense you keep an eye
on your d3 pawn and you also pressure
the night well the pressure tonight
means you also pressure the e5 pawn but
here mokuba actually went for Bishop to
b3 and he he's offering the d3 pawn now
this has been played only once before in
2012 and that game actually ended in a
draw so let's see what happens here I
see Benko rises up to the challenge he
he cleans the pawn queen captures on d3
we have bishop the c2 pushes the Queen
Queen back to d8 where the queen is
safest and now Quinta e 2 and now
attacking the e5 pawn and there is a one
game one we've mentioned where Bishop to
g4 was played but here we have Bishop to
d6 just defending the pawn and it is as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so let's see what max would look
prepared for us he was before he starts
just expanding on the Queen side
he says he is much better developed and
he wants to take even more space so
Queen to e7 developing the Queen now
that the light progression will be
developed the rooks will be connected we
have rook to e1 and now f6 just
strengthening that a5 pawn but it also
opens up this diagonal so you win some
you lose some
we have 84 and now preparing to grab
more space with a 5 but of course black
now plays a5 with b5 pushes the knight
back Knights to d8 and now Knight d4
here offering a knight for an ice queen
trade and if you go for this then it's
it's basically just just a trade down
into somewhat of an equal endgame rook
captures D captures on c3 94 and now
it's not all that easy to develop with
with black you have to be careful the
two bishops this one's coming to b3 this
one's coming to a3 are going to control
a lot of squares c3 c7 is under attack
if you develop the bishop now it could
be it could be very difficult for
example if you try to just pick away the
room just rotate check rook f8 and
Bishop b3 you cannot move the King due
to checkmate so you have to block with
the night and now captures captures
Bishop the a3 check and it's just a just
a very well unpleasant position to play
for black if you went t e8 it's Ted and
rook to e1 is very strong and well for
the moment you are up material but but
not for long you're gonna lose this pawn
and well the rook will find his way up
up the board at some point but okay now
after this bit a night the d4 move I see
Peng who goes for g6 instead takes away
the f5 square from the night and now f4
trying to now get black the capture but
we have Knights to e6 now offering a
trade of Knights now f captures on e5
and Knight to f4 and this is where the
magic happens
now here obviously you should move the
Queen your queen is under attack and if
something like Queen e4 is played then
Queen captures on e5 let's say Knight
attacks Queen we probably have a queen
trade ended the game continues however
here max to blue plate he captures on d6
and this is just crazy
you might think okay a queen for a queen
but not really this Queen hangs with
check so it might seem like max ooh
blunders his queen but he actually gave
up give up his queen for for two minor
pieces and a lot of activity so okay
Knight captures any - with check we have
rook character Sonny - and now you
cannot go after the pawn if you go after
the pawn then again the bishop repair
from hell emerges after King g7 Bishop
to a three and now you might even lose
more material but even after Queen d8
you could go Bishop to e7 and now the
Queen doesn't really have any any
squares to go to for example you could
move the Queen Queen either but now
Bishop captures here just wins back the
Queen so a lot of a lot of ideas here so
instead I see panco just goes back Queen
back to d8 and now Bishop to b3 with
check King h8 and Bishop to a three now
now the bishop pair is fully operational
and black has to decide where to go from
here we have C captures and d6 and now
rook 81 the rooks are nicely doubled and
the knight occupies an excellent the d4
square you still have to figure out what
to do with this night but all in due
time
so Bishop to g4 I see Penco develops the
bishop with an attack on the roof so he
doesn't waste time rookie three and now
d5 it's been who gives up the rook for
for some activity and also he prevents
this Bishop from yeah well from pretty
much doing anything but this Bishop is
not pretty bad and maxilla doesn't want
the trade here he prefers to keep his
Bishop air he goes h3 forces this Bishop
back Bishop to d7 and now Knight the e6
and okay the Queen and the rook are
under attack so Bishop captures we have
rook captures and the Queen to c7 now
going after the c3 pawn so rook to e3
defending the pawn and now rook f7 not
allowing any rook to e7 tricks so what
do you do here
Bishop to d6 first and in between move
attacking the Queen Queen to c8 and now
Bishop back to a3 asking se panco what
do you want to play here so it's panco
decides that it's time to grab one of
the bishops Knights the c4 but mocks
fool doesn't mind since this bishop
really isn't doing anything here Bishop
captures D captures and now Knight to f3
Queen back to d7 now again you're trying
to get to this final rook into the game
nice to d4 now and here you might okay
you're up a queen but how do you
activate pieces this rook doesn't really
have a good square your C pawn is
blocking the C file you cannot own the
e-file because white owns the e-file and
well the other rook pretty much doesn't
doesn't have a a good plan eater so
Queen to d5 first you activate the Queen
we have Bishop to e7 now hoping for
Bishop captures and f6 with check but
Queen g5 defending the show back to a3
again max Lulu says okay you come up
with a plan with h5 we have the Shabak
the east 7 and the now comes King to h7
we have Knight to f3 now attacking the
Queen Queen to f5 and now Knight d4
pushing the Queen back and now Queen to
be one with check King h2 and now
finally rook 88 with the best of being
on e7 it is possible to activate the
rook however it comes with the price of
a pawn so Bishop captures on f6 we have
rook captures on e6 rook captures and e6
in the now well you could try and play
something here but it's not all that
easy to find a move for black all of the
pawns are nicely protected and you are
probably gonna see some like Knight f3
Knight to g5 check could we could be
somewhat of a problem after let's
somehow we figure out how to defend the
bishop could be it could become
unpleasant so here I see panko instead
decided to go for rook captures an f6 he
doesn't want all of these pieces dancing
around the black king
so rook captures on f6 and the now King
g7 pushing the rook back rook the e6 and
the now Queen to c1 going after the c3
pawn rook e7 check King of 6 and now
rook captures on b7 winning the b7 point
and now creating a past beep on we have
Queen captures on c3 and then now rook
the B 6 width check King to g7 and now
96 check we have King to h6 and now look
the c6 making room for his pass Ponte
start marching forward with Queen to e5
width check King H 1 and now Queen to a1
with check King to h2 and now feel free
to pause the video and try to find how
to continue this game with black as you
are basically winning you just have to
win it properly so well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding well it's not not an easy
maneuver to find and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
quickest way to go for it is Queen to e5
with check now you force the King to
move back
kingi one now Queen e1 check King back
to h2 and now Queen to b4 and here with
the King being an h2 night here
rook here you pretty much put white into
sort of a tube swung as you cannot move
the rook anywhere up and down since the
knight hangs if you start pushing the
pass pawn the rook hangs and there
really isn't much you can do you can
start by weakening your your Kings
position but it will only make it easier
for black to check you and maybe connect
to some double attacks so nice to d8 now
defending the rook and now Queen f4
check King h1 and Queen to d2 and here
you are just gonna promote your past
pawn and that's it
of course the knight is hanging as well
so not much you can do here now let's
say you move the knight 96 but now just
c3 and now if you both start escorting
your passed pawn
this one Queens with check so after
captures captures check King H - Queen B
1 you are nicely guarding the queening
square black wins the game however after
this King - H - move se panco did not go
for this maneuver put the Queen e5 -
well okay - e1 back to e4 instead he
went for Queen captures on a4 and it
makes sense
you white still cannot pull the pawn
because the rope hangs but he overlooked
something something very important so
feel free to pause the video and figure
out what he overlooked here while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
night covers g5 and g7 and if the rook
came to h8 this will be made so the move
we we need to play and of course the
move
mock's will be played is rook the c8 now
unpinning
you will be able to push her past pawn
and of course black cannot capture
because rook the h8 is checkmate
so here g5 freeing the g6 Square for the
king but now b6 now mokuba starts
pushing his passport Queen to b4
attacking the pawn here also threatening
Queen to d6 check however now comes
Knight to d8 another excellent move it's
it's excellent because now Queen d6
checking each one and Queen captures
pawn results in rook to c6 check pics of
the Queen and after captures captures
the knight will easily stop both of the
Queen side pawns you will activate your
King and most likely a draw will happen
so after Knights to d8 we have c3 by
black and now b7 the night also guards
the b7 square so that's that's a plus we
have c2 and now the you cannot go after
this because just captures captures and
black gets another Queen inter game so
here in muck Zulu has the capture and
now Queen to d6 width check King h1 we
have Queen to d1 width check and now the
King has to again come to h2 but now
Queen captures on d8 guarding the
queening square we have worked the c8
again threatening to promote here and
now we have Queen to d6 width track King
h1 we have Queen to d1 with
check king h2 we have Queen 2d6 with
check King each one and here again queen
to d1 with check king h2 and it was in
this position unmoved 62 that the MUX
will go in this pinko agreed to a draw
as the no progress can be made by either
sides black can only continue checking
he cannot allow this opponent to become
a queen and under than that there's
really not not much to do so really
really insane game beautiful pawn
sacrificed by Mac Zulu then an even
greater Queen sacrifice by mark Zulu if
you run this game through the engine the
engine will tell you that machs will
lose Queen sacrifice is just bad that
there that that he's lost but then again
who knows he as he did prepare this pawn
sacrifice he might have had some sort of
a super engine where he prepared this
line that that says that the Queen
sacrifice is actually okay because if
you look at it from a human's
perspective you actually do get a lot of
play a queen for two minor pieces so I
guess it's possible but either way it
was really really a beautiful game but
both of them and in the end a draw is we
all will deserve the black both of them
so a queen is very strong but you know
minor pieces do do have their magic so
to say but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said this was
the penultimate round and going into the
final round both masculine they see
panco along with the Vanco and the
dogged peruvian are leading the
tournament so we'll see what happens
there or if someone can catch up to them
someone maybe maybe maxime beaugeois
grab or there are some other big names
still with half a point trailing behind
them so we'll see what happens so I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank the Emperor captures captures
under it and richer pitch Alexandre Mika
avez-vous and Alexandra Schaefer for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the well coverage we are at
the last round of the Gibraltar masters
and then continuing the morphe saga
until our next big event so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day